and the hawks have to make a decision
here you think they got a foul kevin
durant goes to the rim and flushes it
down
the red puts the nets in front by five
i don't think anyone fully was aware
that they needed to come up and foul or
they were just slow in keeping up with
the ball movement by the nets but
nonetheless
collins was looking to do it the rant
goes quick
some breathing room for the nets after
uh vanessa having a some time guarding
that action
durant oh wow the tarantula just threw
it down over batons
you know they're gonna start relying on
the jump shot but kd is like
forget that i'm going back to what i was
if not better than what i was and plays
like this
back here rachel is drumming misses
the rat comes the other way
durant crossover and the slam kevin
durant
by high percentage how about kevin
durant the crossover and tells andre
drummond find your business
mama enjoying her son cheesy rice and
all
11 second different shot clock to game
clock dotson loses it walking the
tightrope
oh blake griffin
razzle dazzle oh
next level
kevin durant the rack attack and one of
the highlights of the year
[Applause]
play of the year
in the regular season finale
razzle dazzle flavor and bring in the
spice
this is just too good
astonishing
the bop
the power
uh oh get ready
playoffs are coming
and thompson got a hand on that push it
ahead romeo langford numbers here
langford kd they're defending
and the nets get the ball back man what
a
horrible
transition opportunity for boston
yeah davis left the game no contavious
caldwell pope today phoenix beat the
lakers by eight to even that series in
the west
had two apiece brown inside another feed
from durant passed away
as we all know lost a legend we lost so
many legends yeah in the nba casey jones
passed away at christmas
that's the reason for the substitution
[Music]
deny by durant smith going to the rack
and duran with the block in transition
come the nets and lead by harden and
durant scores
[Music]
deny by durant smith going to the rack
and duran with a block in transition
come the next lead by harden and durant
scores
brooklyn by 12.
romeo langford trying to check durant
brown is open inside we saw bruce brown
spring feed free in the paint he's not
asked to do it as often as maybe some of
the other players but kevin durant over
the years has shown
that he can make plays via steve nash
just raving about joe harris earlier
today all the little things that he does
so well again up top this time durant to
claxton the rest of this quarter
so now brooklyn goes small here claxton
out gave him great minutes tonight
durant for three got it kevin durant
pours it in from three-point range
durant now played by
tucker
durant
pulls it back for the jumper yes
and durant's so good so talented right
there right here tucker getting into kd
trying to use his physicality his
strength against him and kd just patient
gets to his spot has the
size advantage
[Applause]
and drew holiday just too little to
guard kevin durant and mark kevin durant
getting it done taking his time patient
able to
[Applause]
tucker all over him
beautiful
[Applause]
bringing it down
it's a two-second differential here's
durant for three yes
custom off the screen middleton
good top finish
loose
[Applause]
and they can just ignite these nets
kyrie irving with a beautiful pass to
his buddy
they call the foul
here's durant
nice one hop pass
i know kd is a great score but he can
facilitate as well just a beautiful read
setting up brown he attacked lopez
from downtown the other night here's
durant for the greens crossover avionics
and hits
plus the foul stunk and kd getting to
his bag find his rhythm draws the foul
brooklyn up early
the ramp
that is left and right spinning
and score i'll tell you what that was
actually really good defense there by
due holiday
final minute first quarter
and a hot start
for the men's oh spinning a beauty by
giraffe
wow
right here great footwork kd ball fake
step through off the glass
that's trying to hold for a final shot
irving
durant 4-3
now milwaukee going to a match-up zone
but you have to be careful with the
perimeter shooting of brooklyn
as you say you have to be careful as
durant has the space
[Applause]
durant from downtown
[Music]
26 for kevin durant
now the rant out of the crowd
durant down the lane and score
kevin durant again he is 28 points
so milwaukee just a rooted performance
here's durant to the rim that hits the
reverse and
ends up on the floor right by the stash
it's not even fair
handles great shooting can finish
brooklyn they go hard they go hard
[Applause]
perimeter defenders in the league and
irving
has skipped it as they come offensively
durant
inside brown and finally points it took
them nearly four minutes as bruce brown
gets the first bucket
durant
being muscled by tucker
now look at the post up a lot of contact
durant turns shoots and scores just his
second field goal he's now two for seven
this next team especially during a tough
one to defend
durant on the drive back to brown the
floaters up and good
ten points four boards for brown
another floater up and good bruce brown
playing some great basketball so far in
this ball game but making their
teammates better bruce brown has had an
impact on this ball game irving to brown
round to harris
durant three-pointer it's good
kevin durant
both coaches have only played eight
players thus far duran drives finds
brown the floater once again bruce brown
14 points on six of 10 from the field
and it's been a rock fight all night
long
durant quick turnaround isolation all
movement player movement running your
sets a must for the bucks durant for
brick
no pace could not get to the rebound a
nice box out by griffin here's durant
across court harris for three
yes
oh does that feel good for joe harris it
is foul
and marvel on this last play kevin
durant because he's got off to a hard
start as being aggressive two three guys
converge on
b.j tucker out of the game holiday
matched up with duran expect a double
team beautiful pass wonderful
beautiful pass for
brown from durant
this small lineup has worked at times
for the bucks given a different look
defensively against brooklyn
here's durant back again
durant makes it home he thought he was
fouled
right here kevin durant smaller defender
durant's ordered by the smaller holidays
kevin durant
must block out keep these bucks off the
glass
[Applause]
beautiful pass right here and brown with
the mask
dunks it on giannis
right now brooklyn in control
well the masked man out there bruce
brown net fans will remember back in
practice when the team was on their last
road trip in chicago durant comes up
with the block
just go up there dribble and shoot
i'm not sure what happened on that play
box
body's flying all over the floor
jeff green has come on for the first
time
for three as he thrills it k.d in
transition hard with the beautiful pass
you had two guys closing out
and pj tucker forcing durant to catch it
way out near half court but duran takes
three dribbles
and he
[Applause]
three-quarter length shot but kd in
transition we're looking at 34 points
nine rebounds durant had it knocked away
ford he was fouled does not get the call
let's get it back
on the drive
gave her the nets a steal that led to a
turnover and durant there for the easy
two
durant trying to shake off littlefield
here's durant on the move
nice folk
and score
just a beautiful move right there great
shot fake
[Applause]
durant racing to the bucket and score
106 105. and kd with the weak side
coming just a beautiful finish
looking to inbound snaps it in to durant
and fakes tucker
with 42 seconds remaining utilized to
determine if the out-of-bounds call was
judged correctly and then on the
previous play durant
once again gets to his spot there
all right
look at him jeff green
gets it into durant here is durant
moving on tucker he turns he shoots yes
with one second remaining
one second left the red hits a three
still a beautiful shot by duran
off balance fading away tucker in his
face
and able to concentrate and step up
and knock down that shot but
from that angle marv it looked like
definitely toe on the line and